Hello Freak bitches.
It's like a joke that you do that fall short.
Like here's a perfect example,
Bill Maher's joke.
Did you hear what he said?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So if people haven't heard the senator from Nebraska,
who was it?
A senator got damn fucking voice among the senator from Nebraska,
I believe.
Uh,
said you should come visit,
we could have you work in the fields and bill threw his hands up and go,
not me,
I'm a house nigger.
That's what he said.
And everybody was like,
what the fuck?
Like what makes you think you can say that?
And when he did a HBO released a statement,
they were pissed off and there was a fire Bill Maher,
Twitter Hashtag thing going on.
That one.
Don't you think to me,
isn't it a little more,
at least I understand the intent of his joke.
Yeah.
He was trying to be naughty.
He made a mistake.
Look,
Pete,
here's,
here's the thing.
He's working on a show.
Okay.
He's working on a very important show for HBO.
That is a very high profile show.
This is extreme amount of pressure,
extreme amount of demands.
There's a lot going on behind the scenes.
He's probably working very hard.
He's probably tired and he's in the middle of this interview and he's trying to
make something entertainment.
The guy gives him an opportunity,
right?
The guy says you could work in the fields and he's thinking work in the fields.
We're going to work with the hills.
Uh,
know who works in the fields.
Slaves work in the fields,
or who's the guy that's in the house?
Okay,
I'm going to say this.
And they just goes with it.
They try to be shocking because he's,
you know,
he tries to be that naughty,
edgy guy and it just was,
it was lame and it wasn't funny.
Yeah.
I get more patient when I watch,
when I see his shows,
he seems like he's,
when he makes a joke and they don't,
he gets mad when they don't fucking laugh.
That's the part that bothered me and he's a silly boy.
But when,
when he,
when he made a joke and it was lame,
he was just trying to be funny,
like he was trying to entertain people.
It's important to him.
His show's important to him.
It's a very good show.
He works hard at it and most of the jokes are really funny and there's a lot of
edgy,
controversial jokes on Bill Maher's show that are really funny.
And he,
that's the line he pushes in.
Sometimes you cross that line and he crossed that line.
Is he racist?
Fuck No.
Is he a bad guy?
No idiot.
No fucking mistake.
He's a human being.
It wasn't like the n word slipped out talking derogatory about,
you know,
he was trying to an exact point about slavery.
He was just trying to be silly.
He was trying to be funny.
He was like,
he's not like being,
remember when dog,
the bounty hunter got caught dropping a bunch of n bombs.
But people,
there's,
there's a way.
Look,
there's no words that are forbidden and the idea that the,
that's that word exists in countless rap songs,
but you can't sing along to those rap songs and you're ransom.
Walmart.
It's ridiculous.
I think those rap songs are banned from Walmart too though.
You and I found out recently,
which is those,
um,
there's Walmart versions of all those items.
I didn't know that.
Oh,
well they,
they take out the cuss words.
Yes.
I fucking ordered a,
an iTunes once,
a copy of a,
one of the dead,
not dead presidents.
Um,
who the fuck was it?
It's one of those like hardcore rap bands.
And uh,
as I was listening to it,
it was all this like backwards shit.
Yeah,
no,
like bleeped out or like,
it was like empty spots where there was the,
I don't,
I,
I downloaded a m and m album and I'll,
I heard all these backwards sounds.
I thought I was like,
you know,
there's the old sergeant pepper shit.
I guess they took it all the bad words and just play them backwards.
Even worse.
I listened to one from gangstarr and they had alternative words,
alternative words,
and I was like,
oh no,
you can't alternate words.
Not,
my thing is getting I out though.
Hip Hop guys.
And why don't you just all those like Jay z or some big,
I go,
fuck this,
we ain't doing this anymore.
I think they're not doing any more,
but the reason why they do this for money,
there's so much money out there.
I mean,
if they can get their shit played on radio and get the more,
it's all about exposure.
I mean,
you know,
it's all about the,
the most amount of people that you can reach with your stuff.
Yeah.
Well I,
they asked me to do a clean version.
I said no,
good for you.
But my,
my um,
my morals definitely cost is going to cost me a lot of fun.
Okay.
Nah,
I don't think so.
I think in the long run it'll save you money because it'll,
it'll elongate your career.
Cause if someone's a fan of yours and they're at a barbecue and someone pulls
out the lame version,
like,
oh,
you got to hear this guy,
he's fucking hilarious.
This guy's crazy.
And then it's like,
F you B itch.
Fub you broke my heart,
screw you girl.
Or you know,
whatever it is.
Well remember when cee Lo Green had that?
Forget you.
No,
no,
no.
Soft.
Forget you.
It's fuck you.
And why the floods?
The song again.
Why can't you say fuck you on the radio to the nineties?
I mean,
I know why,
but yeah,
it's like,
it's stupid because a long time ago people were dumb and they thought that the
son was 17 miles away and they saw it.
There was an old man living in the clouds that was,
had friends that used harps and that,
uh,
you gotta be careful with words.
You are clinging onto the,
I mean,
it's the same thing and like,
you know,
TV and radio,
they're like,
there's still like,
but like,
dude,
he's like,
there's a,
there's youtube.
Like,
you know,
we did it,
it,
we,
we premiered another video from this record again.
We did the pornhub premiere,
you know,
like,
fuck this,
let's reach the people fuck up.
Yeah.
You premiered on porn hub,
which is hilarious.
How did that come about?
Um,
I reached,
I,
uh,
what happened was my,
my people were just kind of like,
you know,
like,
let's find a place to premier.
You know,
they always do this thing where like you can premiere a video on like,
I don't know,
will it be an example like a v club or some shit,
you know,
and,
and we're rolling stone or something.
I go,
give me those numbers if you know it's like so and so gets 50,000 when I go,
what about look up porn hub's numbers.
It was like 200 something million.
I think one of the,
I think we're rolling stone was something like the 8000th or something.
Biggest website.
And I go check out what porn hub is in porn.
I was like number 19 in the world.
And I go,
well I'll go,
I'll go,
let's just reach out to them and see if they'll premiere will be the first guy
to premiere country music video on porn hub.
The problem is when people go to porn hub,
they're sweaty and nervous and they're just thinking about beaten off.
Well to get in the wrong mindset.
Well I think it,
I think after you beat off your,
you ready to fucking chill out and listen to some good country.
Yeah.
But you're also ready to hide what website you were watching.
I don't know about your browser in a race and your history.
It fucking worked man.
I mean I've seen,
I saw a lot of people,
you know,
like uh,
I don't know how many people I can tell you that came up to me like I first
heard about you because they don't want to admit it,
you know?
But the numbers show that people fucking,
so it was crazy cause we premiered it on pornhub and they were like,
it was almost like,
you know,
if you guys do this for me,
I'll show that you know,
it works and sell.
You can sell things besides fucking boner pills,
you know?
Right.
Well it's also,
it's one of the things that if you did it,
just knowing that you did it,
people would go there to check it out.
Like he's,
he's premiere to shit on pornhub.
Exactly.
You go there to check it out.
And it's funny cause I,
if we put it up at like noon or something,
I was like,
I thought it was like hundreds of millions.
I think the views aren't that high.
And someone there was like,
wait til five o'clock when people get off work and stop beating off.
Yeah.
It was like at five o'clock the numbers fucking just shot through the roof.
It's like once that fucking work bell rang,
it's like they were fucking,
yeah.
People get in trouble for beating off at work.
Right.
You can get fired.
Yeah.
It's a bummer.
I wish there was like a section,
there is no country music section of porn hub.
Yeah.
You think there would be due to just be the Wheeler Walker section?
Right now I gotta figure out how to,
because I set up my own channel to,
um,
to promote that video and I've got to figure out how to turn it off.
I get alerts on my phone every fucking two minutes,
so and so clicked like on your porn hub video or so and so,
like from like left a comment on your porno videos.
Like,
I gotta get that shit off.
It's all day.
It's like I wake up the middle of the night to like your phones and it's like,
um,
you know,
Trump just 44 days.
Your,
your,
uh,
your new,
your new song.
[inaudible].